dans la région russe de course au nord
de la frontière ukrainienne une colonne
de fumée s'étend sur plusieurs
kilomètres la conséquence d'une attaque
de drones ukrainien d'après Moscou autre
scène capter la veille cette fois-ci sur
la base militaire d'Engels au nord du
Caucase il est 6h du matin au local
lorsqu’un son vient fondre l'air
quelques secondes plus tard un éclat
lumineux celui d'une explosion
ces images satellites fournies par la
société maxar montre des dégâts sur
cette base ainsi que sur celle de
daguilevo rapidement les autorités
russes accusent l'Ukraine d'être à
l'origine de ses frappes les tirs
ont été interceptés par les forces
russes la chute et les débris dues à
leur explosion ont endommagé légèrement
la carlingue de deux avions sur les
pistes trois techniciens militaires qui
étaient présents sur le tarmac ont été
tués
car jusqu'à présent l'Ukraine ne dispose
officiellement pas d'armes capables de
frapper aussi loin en territoire russe à
plus de 800 km de carquis
dans la même journée côté ukrainien plus
de 70
îles russes ont été tirés dans tout le
pays dont 60 aurait été détruit par les
forces entières
je veux remercier les forces de défense
entière nos ingénieurs en énergie et
notre peuple la défense entière à abattu
la plupart des missiles les ingénieurs
en énergie ont déjà commencé à rétablir
l'électricité notre peuple n'abandonne
jamais gloire à l'Ukraine keV comme la
plupart du pays connaît des coupures
importantes d'électricité d'après
l'opérateur national toutes les régions
du pays doivent mettre en place des
coupures de courant pour maintenir
l'équilibre entre production et
consommation